[Musique]
il a été acquitté de toutes les
accusations de corruption au criminel il
a réussi à embrouiller les procureurs la
commission charbonneau mais cette
semaine on a de nouvelles révélations
sur ce que 5,5 qui nous servait de la
collusion montréal
en 2011 montréal est une ville corrompue
c'était corrompu de partout partout où
niveau contrats publics de construction
une métropole sous la loupe d'une
commission denquête on avait de la
corruption a dit en pleurs je me joue au
golf a eu sa part du butin devant
laquelle quelle estimation de ce que
vous auriez pu recevoir en argent
comptant 500 mille dollars et on
arrivait du financement illégal de parti
politique et il m'avait décote dit la
lettre quelques femmes comment demander
sans mines les plus gros sont vos
demandes et 200 milles à l'heure on
avait de la collision donc du partage
contrôle qui
tour à tour il est témoin explique le
fonctionnement d'un système frauduleux
de partage le contrat entre certaines
firmes de génie pour participé au
stratagème les firmes doivent donner de
l'argent parti au pouvoir je donne et je
sais que je vais recevoir
cascadeur et partir à égal
c'était bernard trépanier tel directeur
du financement du parti du maire gérald
tremblay personnages mal acquis qui pour
moi ne sortait d'un film ou d'une autre
époque c'est vraiment la personne loyale
et enfin encore la blague thomson comme
celui qui est seul aucun frais au
stadium
comment vous avez appris ce ciel denis
gallant à leurs procureurs à la
commission charbonneau lui fait avoué
qu'il était l'un des artisans de la
collusion entre les firmes de génie à
montréal je voulais me retourner au
meilleur de ma connaissance la séance a
été retourné l'ascenseur ça veut dire
quoi j'essayais au moins d'elle elle est
comparée combats et mes données de
l'ouvragé à ce qu'avait compte mur bâti
les projecteurs se braquent alors sur
les élus le maire nie toute connaissance
du système je n'ai jamais fait d'
aveuglement volontaire que ce soit et
vous naïf que je ne suis pas naïf je ne
suis pas une personne naïve et les
questions que je demandais qui était le
cerveau du partage des contrats à
montréal pendant cette époque là c'était
frank zampino quand vous aller souper
avec fred michel vivoux zotac le robot
avec le boss est demeuré de la ville
mais aussi qu'on est avec l'homme le
plus puissant de montréal je suis peut
dire ça comme ça frank zampino le
président du comité exécutif de la ville
de montréal ni avec vigueur toute
implication donc autres les témoignages
qui ont lieu devant la commission jamais
vous n'aviez entendu parler d'un système
de partage de contrats sur les nommant
rien jamais
identiques l'un des deux qui m'a
forcément
zampino on assure que bernard trépanier
ne se mêlent pas des contrats publics
ce n'est pas monsieur trépanier qui est
la responsabilité de la gestion
contractuelle à la ville de montréal
or nous avons obtenu des documents qui
contredisent le témoignage de frank
zampino copie le fax qui date du 26
octobre 2004 je vois que c'est une page
d'un voix d'union montréal donc
l'adresse de deux du parti politique
union montréal si le défunt parti du
maire gérald tremblay
l'expéditeur du fax et bernard trépanier
je vois un contrat avec un numéro de
projets de numéros de projets 4002 à eux
il s'agit d'un appel d'offres pour la
gestion des eaux usées ce fax et envoyé
la veille de la fermeture de l'appel
d'offres
suggestif genivar six mois à dos aaa et
monte à 400 milles
genivar ici ma sont effectivement les
films qui ont remporté le contrat
l'époque comme le souhait de bernard
trépanier mais à qui est envoyé sfax qui
est envoyé à frank zampino de bernard
portet commentaires
tard mais c'est fait
frank zampino
le numéro deux de la ville et bras droit
du maire tremblay comment ça se fait
qu'un organisateur politique que pas
d'un rôle
officiel envoyé au président du comité
exécutif nous avons obtenu 6 fax
similaire pour six contrats publics
bernard trépanier indique frank zampino
quelle firme doit décrocher les contrats
et celles qui doivent présenter une
soumission de complaisance est ce ça
fait partie du système c'est à dire ils
savent à quel prix raterez et donc des
firmes qui savaient qu'ils devaient
viser plus haut pour laisser passer en
leurs compétiteurs absolument mais le
stratagème ne fonctionne pas toujours
certaines firmes ne décroche pas de
contrat comme prévu ce qui est arrivé ce
que niang y
ont échappé en cours de route ce
qui n'était pas prévu c'est pas prévu ok
riches est ok
plusieurs de ces facs sont envoyés un
numéro de la région de montréal
dans cette vidéo obtenue de source
confidentielle un enquêteur demande à
une employée de la ville d'authentifier
numéro de fax
l'ifi la provenance de ce numéro là et
si tu as aussi la cua se déroule au
c'est un numéro de téléphone
la résidence de monsieur pinault puis
c'était le numéro de fax de son numéro
deux
je ne confirmerai pas non plus que je ne
le gêne pour le pôle excuses officielles
c'est tellement bien dis donc à moi
d'avoir un document comprend qu'on reste
dans la possibilité de l'impossibilité
où un bon mec label
avoir pu avoir beaucoup pesé avec c'est
avec ces documents dans les facs ont été
découverts lors d'une perquisition dans
les bureaux d'union montréal
ça faisait deux documents que j'aurais
souhaité avoir
ajustements pour confronter des témoins
ces documents n'ont pas été présentés
lors du procès criminel 2-1 pinon pour
fraude complot abus de confiance des
corruptions en lien avec la collusion
des procédures ont été stoppés en raison
d' écoute électronique il légal
dossier super béton de l'administration
montréalaise poursuit maintenant un
pinot aux civils on comprend maintenant
que le tribunal aux criminels reconnus
non coupables monsieur à mme pineau
cclin pour la ville de montréal que
monsieur m pinault à une participation
landes on est très confiants d'aller
récupérer des sommes dix ans après le
début de la commission charbonneau la
ville réclame 45 millions de dollars à
frank zampino conjointement avec
d'autres personnes et entreprises qui
auraient participé à la collusion au
lieu de se dire on va pas réussi parce
que c'est long au contraire ça doit nous
motiver ces sommes-là ont été
chercher dans la poche des montréalais
on en a pas eu pour notre argent et
l'attitude fouetter flex
même si la ville a gan cause les
montréalais ne vont pas obtenir grand
chose frank zampino seraient ruinés ils
continuent encore aujourd'hui de clamer
son innocence
après des années à se défendre devant
les tribunaux l'ancien homme fort de
montréal doit des centaines de milliers
de dollars à ses créanciers
je
[Musique]